hey 42 here on the island of Sicily you
will find a gravestone
it reads flama sekito lived 30 years for
34 times 121 times fought to a draw nine
times a Syrian by nationality you might
not know it but you are looking at the
gravestone of arguably the greatest
gladiator who ever lived
flama which means flame was a soldier in
the Syrian army who was captured by the
Romans sold into slavery and tossed into
the gladiator arena but it was here that
he would find his calling living for the
fight Plummer fought as a sec eater
which means he wore a big metal helmets
wielded a Roman Gladius a legendary
Roman short sword against the reti aris
an incredibly agile highly skilled
opponent armed of a trident and a net
the reti Aras meaning net man was styled
after a fisherman using his weighted net
and Trident he would trap his opponents
and skewer them alive alternatively he
would use his net to entangle his
opponents weapon but flama as a sekito
meaning pursuer would hunt his opponent
down like a sword-wielding Mike Tyson
and dodging his net in the long reach of
his Trident rip him to pieces with his
Gladius flama was so successful and
talented in the arena that he quickly
became a celebrity on the face of a
Roman coin but perhaps most
extraordinary he received the Rudess a
wooden sparring sword that meant he had
won his freedom not once but four times
and each time he turned it down
apparently retirement from this brutal
and often fatal sport wasn't quite his
thing eat your heart Russell Crowe
interestingly seeing that recent studies
have suggested gladiators were mostly
vegetarians he may also have been the
toughest vegetarian of all time there
have been countless Warriors for history
but what makes one truly great and earn
legendary status is it his fighting
prowess his bravery what he used his
skills
to accomplish or it may simply be
someone who regularly confronts death
and is a master of his form of fighting
someone whose accomplishments stand out
even to this day there has been Leonidas
to first of Sparta the legendary Spartan
King who led 300 Spartans against Xerxes
you Fae who fought in a hundred and
twenty six battles and never lost Prince
Rupert of the Rhine who was so gifted in
battle his enemies believed he possessed
supernatural abilities or Simon Bolivar
who during his campaigns rode 123
thousand kilometers more than Hannibal
Napoleon and Alexander the Great or
there is the bravery of the Anzac
fighting troops that led German
commander owynn Rommel to say if I had
to take hell I would use the Australians
to take it and the New Zealanders to
hold it but from all these incredible
warriors there are some so unique that
they stand out amongst arrest Mongolia
has been the birthplace of some of the
most savage and gifted warlords the
world has ever known the Mongolian
Empire to this day stands as the largest
contiguous Empire in history largely due
to the unstoppable aggression of Genghis
Khan Mongolians have historically been
unmatched archers and horseback and
could rival far more technologically
advanced foes that's why when a woman
emerges from amongst their hordes and
start handing them their arses it's time
to take notice cut alone was a 13th
century Mongolian warrior princess she
was a great-granddaughter to Genghis
Khan niece of Kublai Khan and the
favorite child of Kaidu
the ruler of Chang Gatti Carnatic
consisting of xin zhang and central asia
and she was one he regularly sought out
for advice and counsel like most
Mongolian warriors she was adept at
horse riding and archery and she would
often ride side by side with her father
in battle taking captives on horseback
as she raided enemy towns but it wasn't
this
that made khutulun stand out it was
something far more unique
you see alongside being able to fire an
arrow through your head whilst hanging
off the side of a horse subtle Mongolian
workers were also fearsome wrestlers and
she was perhaps the best of them all
khutulun would often dress in men's
outfits and challenge enormous warriors
to a match she would always win when her
father attempted to marry her off a
fiery in headstrong khutulun refused
telling her father she would not marry
any man who could not best her in
wrestling amused at his daughter's
defiant spirit Kaidu set up a simple
competition if he could defeat khutulun
you could marry her if you failed you
had to give her 100 horses men came from
all corners of Mongolia to face her in
combat and her father watched as her
would-be suitors faced her one by one
but by the end of the competition
khutulun remained unmarried and had
10,000 more horses to her name I'll let
you do the maths on that one one such
fight was recorded by none other than
the legendary traveller Marco Polo
himself he wrote that a wealthy handsome
and powerfully-built Prince once arrived
to fight khutulun he had healthy
beautiful horses a huge body of servants
and everyone around whispered that this
was sure to be the husband of khutulun
when word got around that the fight was
to begin a huge crowd which included
polo himself gathered to watch the
combatants locked arms with the Prince
immediately demonstrating that he was
far more than any ordinary opponent with
the crowd of spectators beside
themselves of excitement the two
warriors went back and forth each
gaining the upper hand for far longer
than any opponent had against khutulun
before but then something unexpected
happened without warning khutulun
shifted her positioning gains the
leverage she needed and viciously
slammed the Prince to the ground
silencing both the prince and the once
excited crowd the fight was over and
Cotulla was victorious although there
are conflicting reports of Catalans love
life there are no official records of
her ever getting married and all that is
clear is that through her legendary
wrestling fighting skill and bravery she
brought so much respect and wealth to
the family but her father wanted her to
be the next con and when her father died
Mongolian tradition made clear that his
heir wouldn't actually be his son but
rather his strongest no prizes for
guessing who that was nobody knows what
happened to khutulun past this point it
is unclear how she died and it is clear
that for some reason she never came to
rule but there is one finger parent in
her story there's never been a warrior
quite like her now everyone knows the
cliche of the lone samurai warrior the
one who wanders Japan cutting enemies
down left right and center all while
seemingly having no real purpose he's
been the inspiration for countless films
comics and cartoons but what if I were
to tell you that there was a real guy
who was just like this and he's probably
the sole reason that the cliche exists
Miyamoto Musashi was a samurai Ronin who
wandered Japan in the 16th and 17th
centuries
killing the most dangerous enemies he
could find so legendary was his fighting
ability but even now he is considered by
many to be the Ken say-or sword saint of
all Japan born in the harima province
Musashi was trained in the art of the
sword by his father as well as the
family art of the jeté an ancient
Japanese police weapon he was soon moved
to a Buddhist monastery where he learned
Buddhism that he would later return to
in his life he was bold and talented and
aged only 13 he faced his first opponent
a reamer Kihei was a swordsman who
encountered Musashi along the banks of
the Sahara the Massassi eager to test
himself charged Kihei and struck him
with his cane and challenged him to a
duel Kihei responded with a slash of his
sword goodbye now Musashi was too close
and tackled the man to the floor where
he then proceeded to beat him to death
with 14 to 15 blows of his cane after
this Musashi traveled around Japan
engaging in more and more duels known to
many as the Musha Shugyo
meaning samurai warriors quest he also
fought in the famous battle of
sekigahara
where somehow suggested he refused to
fight as his Lords vassal which is
perhaps the moment he became a true
ronin a masterless Samurai and it was
here that sort of his most legendary
duels began he went on to gain a
reputation as a master swordsman and was
awarded the title unrivaled under heaven
by shogun ashikaga yoshimasa si
challenged
Yoshioka seizure o the master of the
Yoshioka fighting school to a duel he
immediately accepted but Musashi was a
far more cunning opponent than he'd
anticipated
using the customs of the day to his
advantage
Musashi deliberately arrived late to the
duel in raging say juror and causing him
to lose his composure when the duel
began Musashi struck swiftly striking
his angry opponents on the left shoulder
knocking him out and crippling his left
arm with leadership of the school now
passing on to Yoshioka densha kira an
equally deadly swordsman Musashi was
immediately challenged to a duel in
order to avenge his defeated master and
restore honor to the school
Massassi eagerly accepted taking place
in kyoto
then she Jiro arrived wielding a long
staff reinforce of Steel and prepared to
kill a disrespectful Ronin but he hadn't
learned from his former masters fate
arriving late Musashi once again threw
his opponent into a rage and within
minutes Musashi had taken advantage of
his poor composure disarmed him and
defeated him out raging and disgrace in
the oshika family but it wouldn't end
here with leadership now falling to a 12
year-old boy named Yoshioka mats Akira
the school assembled a small band of
swordsmen archers and even Musketeers
and having challenged Massassi to
another duel waited for him to arrive
late and end his life but Massassi had
done something completely unexpected he
had arrived early hiding in nearby
bushes Massassi sprang into the middle
of his opponents and ferociously
attacked startled and an experience mats
Ichiro was almost immediately slain and
then Massassi
escaped defending himself against the
archers musket fire and the pursuing
swordsmen under incredible pressure
Musashi was forced to draw his second
sword in order to survive and using it
to successfully escape
it was here he invented his own unique
style of samurai fighting called mitten
itchy real fighting with two swords but
as shocking as these jewels were his
most legendary jewel was yet to come
after fighting over sixty jewels and
never want tasting defeat
there was only one opponent who was
thought to be an equal if not superior
to Massassi Sasaki Kojiro the demon of
the western provinces in an age where
sword fighting was a really big deal
these were the two biggest deals of all
Sasaki was perhaps the most feared
warrior of his time he was composed
fearless and the exact opposite of
Musashi respectful and an adherent of
tradition he wielded a nod a key a huge
Japanese sword almost three feet long
and
heavier than a normal sword but despite
this Sasaki was said to wield it with a
natural speed and power a duel was
arranged on the island of Fuu nojima and
standing on the beach with his hand
resting in the hilt of his sword
Sasaki waited for his opponent arriving
late and by boat Musashi swaggered up
onto the beach with an unkempt
disrespectful appearance that outraged
Sasaki's supporters but this wasn't
Musashi's only plan Sasaki drew his
enormous non Duchy and prepared to fight
only to be met by Musashi's weapon
ibaka a wooden sword that he had carved
from the awe of his boat and one that
was just as long as Sasaki's the fight
began within seconds Sasaki had struck
but when his blow came down Musashi was
not there he was standing to his side
and all of a sudden
Sasaki felt himself stumbled back then
fall to the ground he did not know what
had occurred but soon he was on his back
staring up at the blinding Sun within
seconds he was dead Musashi had brought
down the bakken onto his head splitting
his skull and then smash it into his
chest shattering his ribs some fear he
stayed up Musashi used a son behind him
to blind his opponent of a state he had
timed the duel so well that he used the
tie to help him escape Sasaki's vengeful
students either way the result was clear
Musashi was still undefeated and the
greatest swordsman the world had ever
seen
later in life when he had done killing
people Musashi retired to a cave
embraced his buddhist roots and wrote
the book of the five rings one of the
most famous and influential books on
strategy and philosophy ever written and
his techniques of taunting mocking and
disrespecting his enemies so they'd
become filled with rage and lose their
composure were so successful that they
were copied by the English at Agincourt
a defeat
French and they were later adopted by
fighters like Muhammad Ali and Conor
McGregor was so far these are individual
warriors all of whom are long dead
is there a band of warriors still alive
who to this day maintain a fearsome and
unrivaled reputation yes with an average
height of 5 foot free it would be easy
to dismiss the Napoles Gurkhas of being
as a disadvantage but you couldn't be
more wrong the Gurkhas have a legacy of
fighting prowess bravery and
exceptionalism that is equaled by very
few in the modern world and it is all
summed up by their motto better to die
than to be a coward and their famous
bladed dagger the querque which is said
to need to taste blood the Gurkha story
began in the 19th century when border
dispute between the kingdom of Nepal and
the East India Company
led to the British being so thoroughly
impressed with the Gurkhas fighting
ability that they did whatever they
could to get them on their side and they
succeeded they were soon incorporated
into the British Indian Army proper
today they come under the banner of the
Royal Gurkha Rifles and are in every way
a contingent force of the British Army
as are the SAS or the Marines except
their numbers are recruited from
Nepalese nationals not British though
Gurkha HQ is in Britain and they are
trained in Britain their impressive
combat record has never not even
remotely diminished with them being
awarded over 25 Victoria Crosses
their highest award of Honor in Britain
and the Gurkhas have perhaps more
stories of exceptional bravery than any
other fighting force on earth for
example I was lucky man Gorham who after
being severely wounded by grenades
successfully fought off 30 Japanese
attackers and survived earning him the
Victoria Cross and preventing his
position from being overrun there was
one a buck to Gooden who when his entire
unit was pinned down by an enemy sniper
calmly stood up blew the sniper away
unsaved his Comrie
later when confronted with multiple
enemy foxholes and bunkers Goering
charges battle didn't wait for orders
and stormed the foxholes and bunkers
solo killing multiple enemies surviving
countless rounds of light machine gun
fire and taking the final position for
himself by cutting the enemy down with
his querque
he was awarded the Victoria Cross there
was Bishnu shrestha who when his train
was bordered by dozens of thieves armed
with knives and Firearms proceeded to on
chief his querque and attacked them so
savagely he hacked a few of them to
pieces before being cut down or
depressor pun who single-handedly fought
off thirty taliban insurgents using
every single weapon he could get his
hands on including 400 rounds of
ammunition 17 grenades a claymore and
even battering a man to death with his
machine gun tripod for this he was
awarded the conspicuous gallantry cross
although slaughtering people isn't
something I approve of the Gurkhas are
certainly very good at it but there are
a few more modern legendary warriors
besides the Gurkhas whose exploit stands
shoulder to shoulder with any throughout
history
Blair paddy Mayne was a heavyweight
boxer Ireland and Lions rugby player an
all-round tough guy and one of the
founding members of the British Special
Air Service SAS the special forces unit
fought to be the most lethal and best
trained in the world in fact the SAS was
the first modern special forces unit on
which all of the forces around the world
have been modelled after doing a stint
in military prison for striking a
commanding officer beating the hell out
of people in barroom brawls and leading
night raids on airfields in Africa
during World War two paddy found himself
in Oldenburg Germany where his unit was
pinned down by enemy fire not dismayed
paddy jumped in a jeep drove around
killing the enemy snipers drove away the
enemy position in the nearby woodland
and patrolled a nearby road ordering the
gunner to pour machine-gun fire into the
enemy positions when this was done with
he
to personally drag his wounded men back
to safety whilst the enemy continued to
fly through the air throughout his
military career he was awarded no less
than four distinguished service orders
the Legion of Honor and the Croix de
Guerre he was also recommended for the
Victoria Cross there was still a
campaign for him to be awarded one to
this day but by now you're probably
thinking that to be a great warrior
you have to Massacre a lot of people but
the truth is perhaps the most successful
warrior of all time never drew a drop of
blood from his enemies all whilst taking
on the South African government Winston
Churchill and the most successful empire
in human history the British by speaking
of course of Mahatma Gandhi because
whilst Gandhi may have been nonviolent
he was very much a warrior and it is his
Warriors philosophy that drove him
towards this type of combat that makes
him perhaps the most successful warrior
that has ever lived and his popular
image of a kindly frail old man doesn't
quite capture his remarkable views he
held about resistance and courage as
fellow SIF players will already know
behind that benign face as a murderous
genocide on maniac Gandhi was a believer
in the power of true masculinity and
despised cowardice in all forms fiercely
believing that nonviolent resistance was
the highest form of courage a form
cowards had no part in and his argument
was simple to defend yourself against an
enemy is brave but to confront death
head-on whilst refusing to harm anyone
that's far braver he believes that
warriors killed out of a sense of
self-preservation which is in essence a
fear of death he believed that whilst
warriors spent years training their
ability to weapons a true warrior
wouldn't let it fall from his hand yet
at the same time he believed any man who
did not resist evil renounced his
manhood Gandhi believed that
non-violence was far more than saying he
won't physically attack your enemy
Gandhi referred to his form of
non-violence as sati cara
meaning truthful force or love force
practicing Satya Gaara means a person
should seek truth and love whilst
refusing through nonviolent resistance
to participate in something he or she
believes is wrong he believed this form
of brave compassion would stir the
hearts of his enemies fill them with
admiration for your dignity and make
them repent he was also shrewd and
cunning and understood at that
persistent resistance was immensely
difficult and irritating for those in
power but when everyone saw that the
resistor or was harmless they would
usually be inclined to take his side
making getting rid of him incredibly
difficult Gandhi is one of the only
well-known figures in history to take
Jesus Henry David Thoreau and Leo
Tolstoy by their words turn the other
cheek and confront evil with love and it
worked with the exception of India and
Pakistan becoming separate countries
Gandhi achieved almost everything he set
out to he defeated the South African
governments largest oppression of
Indians
he led nonviolent marches that prevented
the oppression of Indian farmers by
British landlords he protested tax on
starving peasants causing the British to
cancel all tax for that
the next he led the famous 24 days salt
march against the British which to
teach' CLE gained him worldwide exposure
and through his quit India movement he
successfully rallied the country made
life impossible for the British and
secured India's independence as a nation
an achievement which earned him the
unofficial title father of the nation he
did every single step of this whilst
facing multiple imprisonment countless
violent beatings and near-death
experiences and eventually a foe who
took his life as far as warriors go he
was unbelievably successful Gandhi's
peaceful warrior resistance is perhaps
what led thinkers like
Bertrand Russell to wonder when
confronted by an invader but he caused
more deaths to resist him with violence
or would resisting him with non-violence
compassion and kindness sway his heart
thank you for watching if you enjoyed
this video then please consider
supporting me on patreon it really helps
me to continue to make these videos the
links in the description also you can
get your hands on a first edition signed
copy of my new book stick if liking it
by heading on over to unban publishing
the links in the description and
pre-ordering yours today thank you